I'm trying to say what up is Big Boogie
check me out on the bootleg cab podcast
the bootleg cave podcast
Kev Kev
bootleg Kev bring it bring it back from
the top now
who we bringing back just
yo what up it's big Boogie check me out
on the bootleg cat podcast
look
boom you nailed that [__] no I
didn't I don't gotta hammer
foreign
podcast we got a special guest in here
is it safe to say you're high as a
giraffe's [__] right yeah you can see
that
you just left be real yeah
he got you smoked out I was smoking
before I got to him damn
that's how we doing huh this is how we
live with big boogies here for sure
uh okay so let's go through well first
of all
talk about the name of your project they
call you the big dude
so there's have you ever watched The Big
Lebowski yeah the dude yeah he's right
there that's the dude as well that's my
favorite movie ever well I remember that
so why are you the big dude
um I call myself a big dude because like
I can't anything come my way
and God don't play about me so it's the
meaning of no big dude to be honest and
to be a dude you got to be a dude you
got to be a dude yeah I have a little
fun right if I can write yeah for sure
yeah what part of Memphis you from
Frasier shout out to Frasier boy we have
Frasier Frasier before show The Legend
hypnotized I remember I bought his album
when I was probably like 11 years old
which dates me well you would know 35.
how old are you 26. well you ain't that
yeah you ain't the youngest of pups
you've lived enough life I'm a young OG
yeah for sure for sure man uh how long
you been rapping man
[Music]
um
like five years now so not too long so
you started rapping me about 20 21. yeah
that's a that's kind of late night
what like gravitated you towards
starting that [__]
um
I was a drum major at first so I really
want to rap it first a girl major so you
were like Drumline type [__] no like I
was the person that was like at the
field on top of the head like leading
the band but you were in the band yeah
nice I was I was the head hey Captain
though oh so you were like you were like
the leader I was the one that was
winning all the battle of the bands and
you know what I'm saying so you were
musical already yeah so you could get
down with some drumsticks yeah for sure
yeah not snares though huh bass drone
the bass drums okay so you that's
obviously kind of a pretty natural
transition because you're already into
music so was there something where it
was just like
what's the career in being the drum guy
nah I just um
I always wanted to be somebody big but I
ain't no yeah yeah the big dude
I was I always wanted to be somebody big
but I didn't know who I was gonna be
though I'm saying but I knew I was gonna
be big someday
it it is but I'm saying like to start
rapping at 21 that's a pretty serious I
mean like you obviously were you good
right away
I mean I was at Rhythm you always say I
mean you got to have rhythm yeah you
gotta have rhythm
um I just didn't I just didn't have
nothing to talk about but I had a lot to
talk about right you know what I'm
saying so like I didn't have a lot to
talk about like stunt wise or but I had
a story though right I'm saying so
Hey where's my where's my process
where'd you go to college
I didn't go to college but um I turned
it down oh yeah I turned it down just to
do this just to grind from the rap so
you uh had an opportunity to do the drug
thing a scholarship and everything we're
at
um I think it was like in Jacksonville
yeah big a big band in Jacksonville it's
a big college though and they offered me
like 15 something like 10 million or
something like that five million
something like that
a scholarship
okay but not five million dollars
perfectly five million dollars yeah what
the [__] are we doing here like word for
y'all like right I'm saying but I was so
younger like wait wait I don't know what
it was are you sure the average you five
million dollars
it was a scholarship like I had to go to
school for this decade
but you get five million yeah it was
somewhere it was in the millions though
listen man
it obviously worked out because you have
a gigantic
pit bull yeah that's got how much was
that one-third 130 it it's all worked
out obviously my little brother
is he did he pass away yeah oh man rest
in peace
that's a crazy chain yeah uh how long
would your brother pass uh two years ago
two years yeah something like that
that's a big loss yeah look at my baby
brother especially being your baby
brother you feel like you gotta protect
him and [__] you know is that something
that like you feel like kind of changed
your life
a lot
each of my attitude maybe your mentality
towards things
yeah it really known me to a lot so a
lot of [__] don't get to me
that's true you go through some crazy
[__] it almost like
it knows you yeah like normal people
yeah no I've been there I've been I've
been through some like wild ass
relationships in my life where I'm like
man I may survived that [__] like just
this ain't nothing
yes you know for sure I just get high
about it I just chill on me I won't be
bothered about it yeah was uh was he a
part a part of the music [__] with you
or yeah he was he was here where I was I
just my baby brother you know what I'm
saying like
yeah that's terrible man I'm sorry for
your loss bro for sure
um so you start rapping at 21 you're
probably not too good at first yeah I
want it's like I was mumbling my words
at first I mean everybody's Flint you
know what I'm saying shout out to other
label rep for coming in here with this
[__] ring around Amir anyway yeah um
real professional brought a Scarface
poster and brought a loud phone
um no but you obviously used like at
what point in time did you catch your
wave where you felt like you were in
your pocket where you felt like you kind
of had like gotten a real grip on being
able to do this [__] catching a buzz in
the city you know maybe learning how to
make songs the right way right versus
the right way you know when I started
seeing more
seeing more yeah like traveling okay
like like when you travel you see more
you talk about it you got more
inspiration so I was like yeah yeah yeah
so it's all it is is what you see and
you just put it put it how you living
for real right so it's like
it's really it's ways with them words
you got to use them so how did you get
on uh Gotti's radar
I was doing my own thing and
um it's like a neighborhood hero that I
was looking up to in the streets right
and that was one of the guided people
that he raised so um he put the book in
murder and so he basically telling me
like keep going like they watching type
[__] like you're a big homie was
somebody who was tight with Gotti yeah
and that was kind of how yeah yeah yeah
he put the word in
and put the word in like they were they
were like look at they were like who hot
in the city and he broke my name up so
he was like hey bro they're looking at
you they and they started looking at me
but he didn't tell me when they was
coming he was like they just looking at
you man like just keep going I ain't
gonna tell you when they're coming what
year did you sign like how long ago
2018. yeah so you were you were a part
of the uh July 26th the awesome press
conference the CMG press conference last
year when mozzie got announced uh-huh
yeah pretty Mozzy by the way he had
three Mosley for sure I just wrote him
in jail yeah yeah yeah
great guy uh is it do you feel like
there's because CMG if we think of like
I think I like the Rockefellers and the
bad boys and the death Rose I feel like
the closest thing we have to that now is
CMG yeah the lineup is crazy God is a
hell of a CEO he knows how to sign
Talent he knows how to pick Talent uh do
you feel any pressure
when you look to the left and you're
right and there's money bag yo and
there's 42 Doug and there's glorilla and
there's mods
like you got yeah you gotta you got a
plan well you're playing on the [__]
Yankees low-key you know what you mean
personal like is it like friendly
competition are you like ain't no
competition if if one win we all win
that's so I don't look at nobody else
bigger than me or smarter than me if I'm
saying like we Nick the Nick with this
[__] all of us so we all doing our thing
we all going hard so when we popping it
you know what I'm saying we represent
Goddard yeah if you don't say he can
really sit back and put his feet up and
be like I just sitting in here anywhere
yeah you feel I'm saying that we gonna
rock anything
were you around the night that Gotti
lost all that money playing Blackjack
no
did it though I just remember hearing
about how much he lost and I would I
would have I would have I would have
been that would have [__] up by decade
man I'm like [__] I think it was like
half a million dollars or something was
there something crazy like that how do
you lose it I think he was gambling I
think Jay-Z was there oh wow see this is
personal yeah no it was I mean there was
I think I think it was on video yeah
yeah I went around yeah anything God has
taught you just in terms like again like
he's been around he grinded from tvt to
the mixtape scene to you know epic to
you know he's had so many different
chapters of his career he's really seen
it on when it comes to this music
industry uh are you like able to kind of
call on him for like advice when you
need it yeah yeah yeah man got it like I
had to get open with him first because
I'm really a shy person right so it's
like
well I'm shy to oh geez you know what
I'm saying right because like
I don't know it's like man got it we we
real close though you know what I'm
saying so even though they don't see me
with him a lot because I'm booked and
I'm saying I mean he gotta pay for these
chains yeah yeah but they pay for it but
it's like I just he don't stop me
getting my money right you know what I'm
saying so he said let me do me he he let
me hustle you got a scar on your head
I was um
I was 11 years old me and my brother
that looks like an 11 year old like that
was like
yeah oh I mean my brother were playing
Whip and fight you heard it playing what
whipping fight weapon fight yeah like
you hit me with a break but I hit you
with a ball in your head wait you threw
a brick yeah that's that's a game in
Louisiana Whip and fight weapon fight
women fight
so you so if I hit you with a you my
brother hit me in the head with a brick
and I hit him in the head with a bottle
I got a Skywalker he got a scar on the
Becky head what the [__] yeah we bad
here bro
that's some wild ass [__] yeah but like
like most like like just my fans they
all this they love it you know what I'm
saying did your parents beat y'all's ass
when they found it cracking bottles and
Bricks over each other's heads
okay if I came home and yeah I got two
sons I come home and one of my both of
my sons are leaking yeah oh but my mom
was on [__] like because it was in my
face it was in my face so that's my only
scar in my face yeah you know what I'm
saying and my mom was like you [__] my
son face up you black [__] oh she
talking like this with my older brother
yeah but he turned around and be like
Bro Look he hit me too so so she like
she sleep on me I'm like I thought you
said something I said and you're a
smaller brother right I'm the middle
you're the Middle Brother Mr Big Brother
who hit you in the head with a brick my
oldest brother Jesus yeah is he here
I don't know if you're right I just like
we should talk how many times did you
guys play this game he don't know why he
hit me though I don't know and I want to
know how did it start did it start with
a brick in the Box I walked outside and
I was I was missing him oh my god oh he
was sitting on the curb he they were
playing ball curveball and my older
brother playing career ball so I ran
over him smacked me back ahead because
he was a ball hit so Smith in Vegas
yeah this the one right here with the
glass bottle so I like I smacked them
back in the head but I ran back in the
house about to you know hide from me
[__] so I came back outside it was
squeakly
I'm glad you didn't die yeah for real
Grace got it but I'm like hit me like a
boom I'm like it's leaking yeah but I
ain't feeling though you know what I'm
saying so now you know with the bottle I
knocked him out though because I tried
to do that if you're the big dude
who is the little dude
the little dude is right here
your brother yeah there's a little dude
God Rest his soul I have a friend we
call him the baby dude he's this little
fat baby wow
His Radio name is Baby Joel but he's
also a dude so we just call him the baby
dude he's a little short fat asian guy
he looks like the baby dude the baby I
gotta meet him you might meet up Super
Bowl yeah
the big dude meet the baby dude yeah
dude together
do some dude [__]
hey we gotta stop the interview to tell
you about our folks at my bookie that's
right baby Super Bowl is coming well you
know in a month or so we got the
playoffs right now you could get those
future bets in on who you think out of
this uh barrage of teams that made it to
the playoffs is going to win the Super
Bowl you could bet player props we can
go NBA action on them so much ways to
make money with all the sports going on
and you could do it all at my bookie
right now if you go to my bookie and you
sign up for a new account use the promo
code bootleg and they will match your
first deposit up to a thousand dollars
you know what's double about my bookie
not only can you bet on your favorite
sports
but you could also get a little
Blackjack going little slot machines in
that thing yummy a little loud little
roulette yeah me so much ways to get
paid on my bookie the most important
thing is though if you sign up and you
use the promo code bootleg at my bookie
go to my bookie my bookie my bookie my
bookie use the promo code bootleg and
they're gonna match your first deposit
up to one thousand dollars right [__]
now
listen I'm a degenerate but I'm pretty
good at this
I've been using my bookie for like 10
years all right very trusted they're the
best trust me they are the [__] best
wherever you're at if you're watching
this you can sign up for my bookie
account one more time that's my book you
use the promo code bootleg and they will
double your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars free [__] money
let's get to it all right boys back to
the interview
hey what UPS bootleg cab here to uh stop
the interview and tell you about
Bluetooth yes do you have a dick does
your husband have a dick
maybe does your boyfriend got a dick
does your wife have a dick who knows
um it could be harder I'll tell you that
yeah blue chill gets your dick real hard
to kick off that new year you know what
I'm saying if you want your dick harder
than
Advanced trigonometry senior year high
school then go to bluetooth.com right
now use the promo code bootleg and get
one month supply for free that's right
free all you got to do is pay five
dollars in shipping
they're going to deliver the blue shoe
right to your [__] door and discreet
packaging all right same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis
in a chewable form
very discreet packaging mailed to your
house you don't have to go to a doctor's
appointment in person with anybody you
don't have to worry about embarrassing
conversations with strangers about your
[__] dick bro nobody wants to talk
about their dick with a stranger I take
that back I take that back
lots of people like to talk about their
dicks with strangers
if you're not that kind of guy or girl
or them all you gotta do is go to
Bluetooth right now and use the promo
code
bootleg and you're gonna get it sent
straight to your door that's right they
also got the new mint chewable that's
the same active ingredients as Levitra
so there's a lot of options to get your
dick right in the New Year it's 2023.
yeah your dick shouldn't be flaccid
after a like nice long stressful night
no your dick should be ready you don't
want to be a you know a victim of too
much stress too much anxiety and then
you look down and you can't stay hard
you imagine how [__] embarrassing
that is you get yourself a nice lovely
[__] young lady you bring it to the
place you're nervous she's a little
maybe she's a little out of your [__]
league and you start thinking too much
and that dick's not going to perform
it's not it's not going to perform how
you'd like it to but you know how it
will perform if you're on that [__]
Bluetooth
you're gonna put in a [__] Luka
donkic 61 Point [__] performance on
that [__] all right so go to
bluetooth.com right now use that promo
code bootleg let's get back to the
interview yeah have you ever done
mushrooms no why not I ain't too big on
it but you haven't tried them no I'm not
trying to but why not no
I'm backwards only one day you'll try
something no I'm not
backwards only yeah
not even so you won't do a pre-roll with
like a yeah yeah we just gotta do
smoking there those backwards man are
harsh man I mean they can't be too hard
on them right that's what I'm saying so
so you're strictly Backwoods never blunt
never paper
never grabbing sometimes but Leafs like
if you're like backwood if I got a
number backwards I ain't smoking under
what I'm saying but if it ain't backwood
Rock home yeah or papers I just can't
stand when somebody pulls out a bag and
they got to pull out this giant Leaf nah
not them not them though it looks like a
[__] not not them pterodactyl's Wing
nah not the big jump yeah and then they
gotta cut it out no I don't know without
it no no there's too much I don't know
what it is who's on the new uh is we're
calling this a mixtape right album album
okay you gotta do you know you gotta
make sure you never know these days yeah
you call it whatever you call it it's
gonna count towards your contract in a
different way yeah who was on the album
just fetch real shout out to Fat Trel
yeah and my boy did he lay that down
like right when he just got out there
like he sent me something when I sent
him something we're always a fan of
federal yeah he was like 16 15 when I
first when I first found out about him
well he was on MMG when he signed with
him yeah wmg yes like I was I was [__]
boys you know what I'm saying are way
back yep like when his dreams was like
like growing like the ugly stage all the
way to now what would you say for you
like I mean besides domestic abuse with
your brother uh how was your childhood
were you like in the streets were you a
pretty good kid because obviously if
you're part of if you're that good at
drums you probably got a pretty good you
probably were pretty good in school or
at least applying were you applying
yourself to like the after school [__]
though at least learning how to do the
drums no no they I was forced to be in
the band okay because I was so bad I it
was like you know you in school one of
them teachers
at like a parent yeah and so I'm saying
and they like bring your ass here you
finna go to this [__] God's
class right here you're gonna do
something right type [__] so I basically
was like oh in the hood in the hood guy
like but I was never I don't shoot dice
I was never robbing right not a
high-head I'm not running from no
police's until I started you know what
I'm saying I started thugging like I
started you know what I'm saying but
I started doing it I did my day to die
got you she's you after your Pops passed
away you kind of got mixed up into the
wrong [__] yeah like yeah I was
definitely I started I started doing I
was I started thugging like I turned to
a thug then yeah you know what I'm
saying like thug and street street guy
they're different
so a thug mean like you just down to
your being you in your own lane but you
but you you popping it though right
that's a thug you know what I'm saying
you don't care what nobody say you thug
life but you loyal at the same time you
know what I'm saying you know right
wrong that's a thug but a street one
like you know they do everything Street
that's fair for you uh Memphis has such
a rich history in hip-hop
how influenced Were You by Memphis
hip-hop growing up and if and if not
Memphis hip-hop what else like who else
were you influenced by just your style I
was influenced by um uh Boosie Birdman
Lil Wayne all the Lil Wayne rappers as a
rapper influenced you yeah Birdman boss
the boss man
yeah boy for sure I
I [__] a bird you know what I'm saying I
got that work by the Big Timers it was
one of my favorite albums of all time
yeah yeah and neither of those guys are
great at rapping yeah and I love I love
how Birdman like he he
people is Wayne for sure he might be the
best CEO ever yeah like it ain't just
about to see your tip though it's just
like
you know what I'm saying like he just
like that type of soul in your corner
everybody don't got that right everybody
want to be like that person everybody
want to step on hey Master P yeah I was
born on Master P you were listening
uh I was I was born to make crack like
this yeah Hey listen I stole a No Limit
chain I mean I'm older than you so I was
like you you were born like
1996. you were born when Master P was
lit when the ice cream man came out yeah
this I was born on him you know what I'm
saying so yeah I go to sleep I got they
put a pill my mom used to put a pillow
under my uh I mean a speaker under my
pillow playing Master P playing Master P
that song
that's how I go to sleep that's amazing
it's a mystical just screaming in your
ear yeah with the dreads yeah man he's
so crazy hot boy is my favorite movie I
just talked to Silk before
um I flew her Hot Boys is your favorite
movie yeah in life yeah hmm how many
movies have you seen a million of them
and Hot Boys starring soaked the shock
as your face hi boys like Silk man silk
just got through talking so no limit so
like I always say that Silk is the best
worst rapper ever the worst rapper no
the best the best worst rapper ever I
must give on that cause he ain't gonna
lose me so you see that movie poster
over there belly that is the best worst
movie ever
why is it worse because it's really not
a good movie but it's great
I love that [__] movie that movie is
nostalgic that movie like reminds me of
a place in my childhood it's amazing I
wish Hype Williams would have kept
making movies
okay what about Richard that's right
it's not belly I like belly but
belly's the best worst movie ever
okay and silk the Shocker is the best
worst rapper ever okay what about
Shadows shot is a classic I sold so many
of those at the Swap Meet [__] that's
how I got my name bootleg Kev I was at
the Swap Meet [__] burning so we shot
us I was shot over when they first came
up shot this is a [__] classic yeah
also I know everything about it kill the
season camera and that [__] was great if
we're talking about just like Cameron he
was he was a d he was my favorite Master
P movie was I got the hookup though
that [__] was great yes that was way
better I stay watching it way better
than hot boys
the guy who was in the movie what was
his name the comedian who played Isaiah
on Friday he died blue you took my um
they used to call them blue yeah the
little dude
he's so funny oh yeah oh he I was like I
had to do walked into the truck yeah
I had Masterpiece shoes bruh
nobody did except me and my school them
shits was ugly why are you wearing them
because I just love [__] Master P I
stole a No Limit chain bro I had that
[__] ghetto dope I had to [__] was
the root chain real of course not it was
like [__] silver I thought it was
like 15 why are you stealing then
you wanted a bad child and I wanted to
feel like I was in no limit I fee you
know I feel I had that I had the Wu-Tang
chain yeah I think but you got the you
know you're CMG I used to walk around
um thinking out with Luanne I was little
I didn't have a shirt around my head
that's funny
with like looking forward to my mouth
and [__]
you say you you love boozy he just
called me yeah he is one of the guys in
rap that if you meet him he'll never
disappoint you because you'll meet some
of your like heroes or the people you
look up to when you meet him you're like
ah he was kind of a dick or he was he
wasn't who I thought he'd be you mean
Boosie and he's like
this is Europe as advertised yeah we we
acted like the you guys act alike for
sure
that could be a good a good and bad
thing because Boosie's wild no he wild
but he's like
like he streaked though of course he is
Street wow and he's and he's very he's a
smart dude yeah yeah he knows right
wrong he knows how to get to the back
for sure he'll Hustler he'll get Eddie
he goes to a city whatever he can steal
anything oh yeah
sell anything whatever bag you got he'll
take it he's gonna say he's gonna sell
it to you whatever it is he don't matter
he gonna get some money these days if I
wanted to book you right let's say uh
somebody's in like Youngstown Ohio or
something and they're trying to book big
Boogie what's what's the what's the
going rate right now you say where I
would say if I wanted to book you to
perform where
Ohio middle of America
30 30. what if it's in Portland Oregon
maybe not the hottest market for you
I dropped the numbers now make it make
sense you're smart
buddy they Gotti teach you that no
that's some gaudy [__] because a lot of
these [__] a lot of these
artists from the south because y'all be
lit if the whole middle of the country
in the South you got to make it make
sense you got to drop the numbers
because you want to expose yourself to a
new market that's smart for sure that's
how you think long man not short for
sure yeah uh for you what is like are
you obviously being a part of CMG would
you ever do your own version of that
maybe trying to start a label trying to
sign artists yeah I already got my label
what's your label called railroad Red
Rum yeah okay well that's you know
Murder backwards yeah
[Laughter]
why Red Rum outside of the obvious where
I mean murder spelled backwards because
like
I'm overtake about
my family you know what I'm saying so as
you should be
you it's it's murder if you play with
anything about my career hypothetically
yeah hypothetically
yeah on Call of Duty of course yeah yeah
you play video games no none
really so what are you doing in your
spare time besides listening cracking
bottles on the back of your brother's
neck yeah I listen to music I listen to
music I um there it is he said music the
way I knew he would music that Memphis
music you know what I mean so you're
listening to music yeah
um
I brainstorm a lot and I'll be a daddy
Did anyone say you look like Michael
Vick kind of who Michael Vick no you've
never heard Mike Vick no am I crazy I
heard a microphone I don't look like him
though you don't think you look like him
a little bit
no maybe I'm being racist wait
anyway hey we got to stop the interview
real quick to tell you about our family
at hard Dean that's right hard Dean Las
Vegas the craziest dispensary in the
world the number one dispensary in the
United States let alone in Las Vegas all
right maybe you're hitting Vegas with
your friends your girlfriends whatever
maybe it's a bachelor party whatever's
going on you're going to go watch the
Raiders suck [__] whatever it is make
sure you pull up to Hardy in Las Vegas
tell him I sent you they got the
craziest selection of Premium cannabis
I've ever seen in my [__] life the
pre-rolls the cartridges the Edibles the
flower all top notch all the best the
bud tenders are so friendly it smells
great it smells so good inside a Jardine
that they have their own Harding
signature scent candle
see I sniff that and I just think of Las
Vegas and picking up some amazing weed
all right so go follow them right now
Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot them
a follow get all the details you need
you can get you some of this fly ass
Jardine merch at hardinglasvegas.com
shout out to our family in Vegas I'm
excited too because coming up we're
going to be doing our very first podcast
from Jardin in Vegas with young gravy oh
yeah it's going down all right let's get
back to the interview hey we gotta stop
the interview to tell you about our
family at Odd Socks that's right the
most comfortable socks in the
[__] world go to
oddsoxofficial.com right now use that
promo code bootleg and you'll save 20
off Christmas time is it coming and let
me tell you something their Black Friday
sale if you're watching this before
Black Friday you might be watching it
after Black Friday but if Black Friday
hasn't came yet just like Cyrus hasn't
came yet it's been a while he's on a
drought guess what oddsocksofficial.com
promo code bootleg 20 off plus whatever
the [__] else is going on with their
Black Friday so and let me tell you they
got some new licenses we got to talk
about boys
particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist and shout
out to all you rappers and people who be
pouring your lean into this [__]
some Mountain Dew Baja Blast socks
Casino great [__] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we get to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [__]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[__] [__] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [__] ethica or
some [__] ass [__] Nike socks
[__] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview so uh talk about what
obviously you got the project out uh
what is next for you the rest of the
year I mean man we got so much left in
2023 the whole team is dropping what are
you hoping to achieve the rest of the
year man everything that come with
success
everything I know I know I know pimp
once
how are you dealing with the stress that
comes with more success
I'm known to it all let it get to me
yeah you got to delegate sometimes make
sure you get a great team around you
I know I know I got a great team around
me so I just
like I just say I'm laid back you know
what I'm saying on on move fast my
career already fast my life already fast
so I I stay humble to myself so you know
I don't do too much I'm I'm laid back
with it I feel like you probably have
some pretty crazy fans yeah I do how do
you deal with like the crazy
one percent of your fans that maybe try
to show up to the hotel room or like
they're just doing too much
oh no
oh no but my fans know they they know
when I be serious anybody got big Boogie
tattoos out there yet yeah they got my
face face names wow yeah if someone gets
the big Boogie tattoo do they at least
get into the shows for free like for a
while for sure because that's um I made
a fan and uh Chicago
St Louis what they have say oh she had
my face where in my name where are you
damn and uh she waited outside the hotel
while I was getting dressed it was my uh
my brother so that kind of fan yeah she
waited outside and I let her come in the
show with me for free yeah that tattoos
yeah like through the through the back
yeah
um it was another concert I saw it
Chicago she was in Chicago too that's
all she and I let her come with me again
wow
all right so every time I see her
yeah that's pretty serious does it also
kind of freak you out a little
I'm like damn you got my face tattooed
on you no see you got to see it no you
got to be specific you can't say it like
dude freak me out then I'd be like I
don't know like I've been kind of
spooked out a little bit I'm not a spook
I'm shocked shocked for sure for sure
cause I'm like
I don't know you also like what's going
on in your life do you have a job are
you are you gonna follow me home are you
like what like you I don't know you like
right what made you what was the
motivation here what were the lyrics but
she told me she said um
you helped me get through everything
that I go through that's amazing and so
I always want to remember you do you
feel like do you feel that kind of
responsibility that you know we just saw
uh NBA young boy just did that interview
where he was like uh saying how
remorseful he was for some of the energy
he put into the world I saw him say he
terrified
um do you feel any sort of
responsibility or do you have any sort
of like uh you know maybe if there's a
song where you before you drop it you
change the lyrics you're like you know
maybe that's a little too much or is
that something that never crosses your
mind yeah like whatever whatever I put I
put it you know what I'm saying I own I
make it make sense I I like to tell the
truth about everything but I like to
have fun at the same time with it are
you punching in are you writing [__]
down how do you report
so you'll have some [__] in the phone
and then other times you'll punch in
yeah like if I if I do a song like okay
I'll write a song right now right right
but you were you feeling record me but
we've been recording like 30 minutes
I got this much right here bro
so I feel like you can feel in the rest
on the spot yeah yeah
that's fair because I've seen a lot you
so I know what to talk about I know
we're not talking about I know how to
put this I know how to put it because I
know how to break anything down to make
you feel me if you could do a
collaboration album with anybody who
would it be hey
yard
hey cut official you and Akon I love him
I can't wait to meet her he won't
disappoint you I know he won't yeah
that's my daddy favorite artist he ain't
disappoint him Akon's a great guy hey
for sure he is he's also got gray hair
[Laughter]
the turkey we talked about it I was like
yo help me understand what's going on up
here he said he went to Turkey he spent
like seven Grand
no we talked I mean him and I talked
about it on the podcast oh so you know
yeah yeah no I literally was like look
man how do I get this whatever you got
going on up here he said no no my hair
is just I just got the [__] you know
widow's peak going and he said you got
to go to Turkey he said he went to
Turkey I don't know nothing about turkey
he said he went to Turkey and he spent 7
500 on his hair I'm not doing it I mean
you have nice hair yeah you got like
you're you're straight up here like Akon
[__] was you know it was it was back it
was bike bike as Plies would say it was
bike you know what I mean the bike bike
yeah
yo what's the best barbecue restaurant
in Memphis if I go to your city right
now where are you taking me
man come on
Memphis Memphis everywhere but me
personally no where are you taking me
where are you taking I'm taking you to
the kitchen right down Jackson down the
street from my block green law I can't
do nothing but take you right there okay
you know what I'm saying so
I don't eat it we're in Memphis what's
up with your guy John Moran out there in
Memphis my boy man he putting on man I
feel like he wants to be king Von no he
he he him he's wild and bro no it people
just that people just kiss with their
kids well I mean you know the like laser
print like the laser scopes coming out
of a car I didn't see it either so we
can
you know what I'm saying do you know do
you know a job yeah I mean I'm a fan of
him nice I admit his mama I made his
admitted well he's the best like if you
watch anybody any night he'd be the
number one guy to watch yeah we're in a
CMG yeah I bet you he'll bro I bet you
I'm gonna put this in the air right now
will drop an album of CMG one day when
it's good it's gonna happen he wants to
be a rapper so bad no he don't I promise
you that he just turned like he won't
even have to rap on it he just wants it
to be I bet you'll be like a DJ Khaled
style okay like John morenco make a song
it's gonna go he's gonna go
viral anyway because who he is no he's
gonna he's gonna be like he's gonna do a
DJ Khaled style album but it'll and
guardio sign him
it's gonna happen
you'll see look you got you shout out to
the boy Dame the boy is coming soon yeah
he's gonna do a boy Dame type album but
it's gonna be John Morant presents what
whatever the [__] no it's gonna happen
no it's not he's he why would you think
that
why would you not think why would you
think this you don't think John Murray
was a basketball player do you think he
doesn't want to put an album out so
would you do it
forget what would you do it do what
would you do it what would you want what
driving rent to do
put an album out yeah yeah why not from
CMG of course that'd be stupid not to
and if you're driving rent he wants to
be you're not a rapper though
exactly he's not a rapper why do you
want to do it he doesn't have to be why
would you want to why you want to do it
because I'm your rapper
I don't know what's happening okay
you're trying to talk me into this no
I'm not
you don't think John Moran would put a
compilation out yeah no
Allen Iverson uh-huh put an album out
because it's terrible how you know
because I listen to him when I was a kid
dude would you do it no I don't know
what's happening okay
listen the big dude yeah you're a big
step what about baby dude the baby dude
yeah big dude
I don't know but I'm big dude
the [__] big dude man yeah appreciate
you pulling up
um go oh listen Super Bowl we're gonna
have some fun out in Arizona
they got great Mexican food there my
Arizona hot as hell you better I'm from
there this way there's a Devin Booker
Jersey hanging up behind you
I don't know
it's kind of cause just where it's at I
mean I don't know since I just were the
closest to miss gets close to uh Mexico
right that's no there's I mean there's
places closer
it's about three and a half was it it
was the desert or something
you're Arizona right
Phoenix no Phoenix it's about three and
a half hours from God damn but it's hot
did you go to the summer
yeah it's crazy
you from her you'll go back
I own a nightclub there you will move
back though no why not you're from there
I live here why
I don't know why you won't go back
what I'm so happy here you got to move
back then I'd move back I'm saying why I
crossed would you say you won't go back
my parents live there why
I feel like if you move why they didn't
move
I feel like things have gotten
interesting
it's not going to be that hot this week
uh duh it's gonna be kind of cold at
night how you know because it's February
this is
I'm there a lot I don't know what's
happening right now neither do I dude
we'll listen man big Boogie yeah we
thought it was big dude the big dude aka
the big dude
okay the dutiest of dudes he's just big
dude that Duty
are you deuterific I'm a big dude you're
the big dude
appreciate you coming through man for
sure there it is